>> Greg: THE LATEST TARGET FOR
RETRIBUTION BY THE FOAMING
ELITES, PATRIOTIC AMERICANS.
THIS DEMOCRAT SAYS WE MUST BE
SUSPICIOUS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
BECAUSE THEY ARE DUDES AND
STUFF.
>> THE GUARD IS 90 SOMETHING ODD
PERCENT MALE, ONLY 20% OF WHITE
MALES VOTED FOR BIDEN.
THEY ARE PROBABLY NOT MORE THAN
75% OF THE PEOPLE THERE
PROTECTING VOTING FOR BIDEN, THE
OTHER IS IN THE CLASS THAT WOULD
BE IN THE LARGE CLASS OF FOLKS
WHO MIGHT WANT TO DO SOMETHING.
>> Greg: PROBABLY RACIST.
WHERE MIGHT THIS POLITICAL
VETTING OF THE MILITARY LEAD?
WILL REPUBLICANS BE
COURT-MARTIALED OR WILL BIDEN
BUILD AN ARMY WITHIN AN ARMY?
ISN’T THIS WHAT THEY EXPECTED
FOR TRUMP?
MEANWHILE THERE IS THIS
WIDESPREAD VIDEO TO INSTIGATE
REPRISALS AGAINST, YES, TRUMP’S
A SECRET ARMY!
>> IN THE YEARS AHEAD, TRUMP
WILL LEAD HIS ARMY OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS, HE’LL ENCOURAGE AND
INCITE VIOLENCE, HE’LL PLAY THE
ROLE OF ARSONIST AND FIREMEN,
START A CIVIL WAR AND SAY THINGS
WERE MORE PEACEFUL WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT BACK.
>> Greg: HE’S GOING TO BE OUT
OF OFFICE WHERE THEY CAN’T LET
HIM GO BUT WON’T THAT VIDEO LEAD
TO MORE VIOLENCE, TARGETING
TRUMPERS?
I’M NOT GOING TO BLAME A VIDEO
FOR VIOLENCE, ONLY DEMOCRATS DO
THAT FOR THE SAME PEOPLE BLAMING
YOU FOR THE CAPITOL VIOLENCE ARE
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO BLAME YOU
FOR THE SUMMER’S VIOLENCE AND
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO BLAMED
BENGHAZI ON A VIDEO.
LAUGH.
IT’S FUNNY.
IT’S HAPPENING AGAIN, THE
TARGETING OF DISSENT BY LABELING
WORDS IS CRIME SO THEY CAN BE
SILENCE.
AMERICANS GET IT, THE LEFT’S
APPROVED VIOLENCE NEVER MATTERS.
YOUR VOTE?
THAT MAKES YOU THE KLAN.
DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE IN
VIOLENCE, THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE
>> I’M NEVER ON THE SIDE OF THE
KLAN PRINCIPLED PEOPLE,
CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL, NEVER
ON THE KLAN’S SIDE.
>> PRINCIPAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSERVATIVE ARE NEVER ON THE
SIDE THAT TREATS THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS THAN LESS THEN, THAT
SAYS YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS
SHOULD NOT EXIST.
>> Greg: JUDGING EVERYBODY BY
THEIR WORST ELEMENT.
WHEN YOU BRING UP THIS CONTRACT,
YOU GET ACCUSED OF WHAT
ABOUTISM, BUT THAT’S ALL HISTORY
IS, ONE LONG WHAT ABOUTISM IN
WHICH THE IDIOTS OF TODAY ARE
THE IDIOTS OF THE PAST, HENCE
THE NEED TO HIDE BEHIND FEEBLE
DISMISSALS, BUT WE AREN’T
COMPARING ACTIONS, JUST THE
RESPONSE TO SET ACTIONS WHICH IS
THE ONLY WAY TO KEEP PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE MEDIA’S DEFENSE OF MOB
ACTION ALLOW FOR MORE IN THE
FUTURE AS THEY COME FOR YOU?
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A SALIVATING
LYNCH MOB FORMED FROM THE PRESS,
ACADEMIA, BIG TECH, THE D.C.
POWER STRUCTURE, LINKING
COMMENTARY TO CRIME IN ORDER TO
DRIVE CENSORSHIP, HARASSMENT,
BOYCOTTS.
ULTIMATELY ARRESTS MAY COME WITH
74 MILLION DOMESTIC TERRORISTS,
WE BETTER GET STARTED.
I WANT TO GO TO A DANA BASH
FIRST.
[LAUGHTER]
IT’S KIND OF WEIRD HOW THE
DEMOCRATS, MISS BASH, ARE SCARED
OF THEIR OWN TRUTHS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
>> Dana: I THINK THAT...
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
TO THE SPOT WHERE THEY SAID EACH
GROUP, REPUBLICANS CONFIGURED
FORTODEMOCRATS
, LIBERALS, EVEN THOUGH THEY NOW
HAVE BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE, THEY STILL THINK
THEY ARE LOSING THE BATTLE.
REPUBLICANS THINK THEY HAVE LOST
THE BATTLE PURE JUST A COUPLE OF
THINGS PEER THIS IS A LIST,
JESSIE.
HERE’S A LIST FOR YOU.
REPUBLICANS TOLD THE DEMOCRATS
WITH THE NERVOUS MINORITY IN THE
SENATE, 50/50, CANNOT MORE
NARROW THAN THAT, WE’VE GOT
GOVERNORS THAT ARE MAJORITY
REPUBLICAN, MAJORITY OF STATE
LEGISLATORS ARE REPUBLICAN,
DISTRICTINGREDISTRICTING, AND A
MAJORITY IN THE SUPREME COURSE.
THEY WERE SET TO LOSE THE HOUSE,
MORE SEATS IN THE SENATE, THEY
DIDN’T DO THAT.
I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE A FRINGE
AND CRIMINALS THAT DID CERTAIN
THINGS, TO SUGGEST THAT IS
BROADBRUSH AND PAINT ALL
74 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH THE SAME
BRUSH THAT OBVIOUSLY IS NOT
GOOD.
AND NOT TRUE.
AND NOT FAIR.
THE MEDIA SPENT A LONG TIME
AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION GOING
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY SAYING TO
HIM WHO ARE THESE VOTERS?
THEY ARE THE SAME VOTERS.
THERE WERE TERRIBLE PEOPLE WITH
TERRIBLE ACTIONS, DOES NOT MEAN
ALL 74 74 MILLION AMERICANS ARE
SAME.
>> Greg: ASSUMING THE BEST IN
THE PEOPLE YOU DISAGREE WITH,
NOT ASSUMING THE WORST, I THINK
I FORGOT MY SECOND POINT.
I THINK THE SECOND POINT WAS
BETTER THAN THE FIRST POINT,
JESSE.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STRONG DEFENSE OF WHAT ABOUTISM.
THAT DEFINITELY NEEDED TO BE
SAID.
125,000 NATIONAL GUARDSMEN IN
WASHINGTON
WHEN 25,000 NATIONAL GUARDS WHEN
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., I THINK
THAT’S A SHOW OF POLITICAL
FORCE, WHEN THERE IS NO THREAT
AND THERE’S GOING TO BE NO CROWD
BECAUSE OF SPEED 26 TOMORROW AND
REPORTS THAT A LOT OF GUARDSMEN
NOT THEY ARE WITH BULLETS IN THE
CHAMBER WALKING AROUND UNHARMED.
I DO BELIEVE YOU GOT TO BEEF UP
SECURITY IN THE CAPITAL AFTER
THE MOB ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL,
BUT IT SEEMS A LITTLE BIT
OVERKILL.
ARE THEY DOING THAT BECAUSE THEY
ARE PARANOID OR ARE THEY DOING
THAT TO INFLAME THE THREATS FOR
INNOCENT TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO
JUSTIFY THE CRACKDOWN?
I DON’T KNOW.
CONGRESSMAN SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
HIMSELF TO ACCUSE THE AMERICAN
NATIONAL GUARD OF PLOTTING AN
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT BECAUSE
THEY ARE WHITE MALES?
BY THE LEFT’S STANDARDS, HE
SHOULD BE CANCELED AND THE FACT
THAT CNN GUY STAND THERE AND
BLINKED AT HIM WAS ATROCIOUS.
HE EVEN GOT THE EXIT POLLS WRONG
AND THAT’S WHAT REALLY MAKES ME
UPSET.
BIDEN WON 40% OF WHITE MALE
VOTERS, NOT 20%.
THE LEFT NEEDS TO STOP ACTING
LIKE COMMUNIST CHINA WHERE WE
WILL PERSECUTE POLITICAL
DISSIDENTS.
THAT’S MORE OF A THREAT THAN IF
YOU CRAZY PEOPLE STORMING THE
CAPITOL IN THE LONG TERM.
>> Greg: JESSE MAKES A GOOD
POINT, ODDLY.
IF YOU WOULD APPLY COHAN’S IDEAS
TO A DIFFERENT RACE, THE
ASSUMPTION THAT A GROUP OF
PEOPLE ACT A CERTAIN WAY, HE
WOULD BE TOAST.
IT’S OKAY BECAUSE THEY ARE WHITE
MALES AND WHITE MALE PLURALISTS
ARE EVIL AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU
WORK WITH THEM, JUAN.
>> Juan: THANK YOU, MR. WHAT
ABOUT.
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS WHAT
ABOUT HERE.
I THINK CONGRESSMAN’S CONGRESS
ELEMENT COMMENTS ARE WAY OVER
THE TOP.
I DO NOT THINK YOU CAN MAKE A
JUDGMENT ABOUT PEOPLE’S ABILITY
TO DO THEIR JOB ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR POLITICAL BELIEFS.
I THINK THAT’S WRONG AND I THINK
IT INVITES THE KIND OF THINKING
THAT GREG IS LEADING US TO.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS IN ALL
FAIRNESS THAT JUST TODAY IN THE
NEWS IT SAYS THAT 12 MEMBERS OF
THE NATIONAL GUARD WERE FOUND TO
HAVE TIES TO EXTREMISTS AND
REMOVED FROM THE GROUP HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
IT’S NOT TO SAY THAT THIS IS
ALARMISM.
IT IS TO SAY THAT A VERY SMALL
NUMBER GIVEN THE HIGH NUMBER OF
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ON THE
GROUND HERE IN D.C., WE ARE
BOUND TO GET EXTREMISTS AND THE
PENTAGON LAST WEEK HAD TO SEND
OUT AN ALARM AND SAY TO
EVERYONE, WE ARE HERE TO DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION NO MATTER WHAT
YOUR POLITICAL BELIEFS MAY BE.
THAT’S WHY I THINK TODAY YOU’LL
HAVE MITCH McCONNELL THE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADERS SAY,
YEP, PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVOKES
THAT MOB AND OTHER IMPORTANT
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
ARE ADDED TO THAT.
>> Greg: THEY SAY YOU SHOULD
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION NO
MATTER WHAT YOUR APPLICABLE
BELIEFS ARE WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY
THEY SHOULD BE DOING THIS TO THE
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN.
12 OF THEM, EXTREMISTS TIES,
WHAT COULD THAT BE?
>> Katie: THE PENTAGON ALSO
CLARIFIED AND SAID THAT NOT ALL
OF THEM HAD ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE CAPITOL, ONLY TWO OF THEM
DID.
MY BIG QUESTION IS HOW ARE THEY
DETERMINING WHAT EXTREMISM IS,
WHAT ARE THEY USING AS THEIR
BAROMETER FOR WHAT COUNTS AS
EXTREMISM.
IF YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP, AS A
DEMOCRAT SAID, OR DOESN’T ENTAIL
SOMETHING ELSE?
REALLY MATCHING UP AGAINST.
AND ARE WE GOING TO HAVE THE FBI
WHO LOST A TON OF TRUST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN TERMS OF
THEIR OWN POLITICAL BIASES OVER
THE LAST SIX YEARS DOING THIS?
I JUST HAVE TO SAY, I KNOW I’M
ALREADY ON THE LIST AFTER I
NAMED MY DOG GADSDEN AND THEY
ARE TRYING TO SAY THAT’S AN
EXTREMIST THING TO DO.
HE IS ALREADY ON THE LIST.
GOING TO GET CANCELED.
>> Greg: THE ONLY LIST I’M ON
IS THE HARRY AND DAVID EMAIL
LIST.
YOU BUY ONE THING FROM HARRY AND
DAVID AND ALL THEY DO IS SEND
EMAILS.